mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
für einmal ist jetzt schluss mit
ansteckungszahlen warnen und anderen
qualen
wir zeigen ihnen heute ein projekt das
in diesen turbulenten zeiten für gute
stimmung und einen beschwingten abend
sorgt kulturplatz zu gast in einem hotel
mit eigener note
[Musik]
heute wollen wir hoch hinaus die königin
der berge ruft willkommen auf den
kulturplatz und jetzt ab auf die rigi
[Musik]
die welt ganz schnell eine andere wurde
da waren auch in luzern musik
studierende in einer päckchen
die situation
dank glücklicher
ob sie hier oben ein tolles projekt
stadt wittenberg sonne
dort hätten wir gleich ein bei
gewöhnlich
[Musik]
dieses haus ist kein normales hotel es
ist eine oase für kultur viele gäste und
das ist ein zufluchtsort für musik
studierende das schauen wir uns genau an
[Musik]
diese hände bearbeiten normalerweise
violine seiten seit corona sind sie
willkommene hilfe in der küche des
hotels berg sonne statt konzerte zu
spielen stemmen musik studierende hier
gemeinsam eine abendschicht rund 40
gäste werden für das abendessen erwartet
ein lichtblick in diesen schweren zeiten
von den angehenden pianisten und
hornisten ist teamgeist gefragt
unter den studierenden ist eine art
schicksalsgemeinschaft entstanden viele
von ihnen stammen aus dem ausland und
können wegen der korona krise nicht nach
hause
so auch die 19-jährige flötistin isabel
meeraner aus italien
und da das wird sich einfach nicht
ausgehen weil ich kann nicht zwei wochen
lang in italien in quarantäne sitzen die
musiker und musikerinnen wohnen in
diesem besonderen studentenheim direkt
an der lucia in der musikbox mit 27
appartements drei flügeln und einem
kleinen konzert sei mit dem geld das die
musik studierenden im hotel auf der rigi
verdienen können sie hier die miete
zahlen und gemeinsam ihr spiel
perfektionieren musikbox und hotel ein
gesamtprojekt konnte man hier einfach
weiter eben alle anderen mussten
wahnsinnig werden oder die vermieter
wahnsinnig werden und weil es einfach
kein problem und man konnte weiter eben
selbst wenn großen die welt still steht
hier drinnen spielt die musik
ich glaube dass der musikalische traum
den man sich als student zu wünschen
kann und was auch schön ist ist dass
wirklich jeder in diesem haus dasselbe
macht wie ich also jeder hat die selbe
liebe zur musik und ich glaube schon
dass es eine ganz besondere atmosphäre
ist zurück auf der rigi im klang hotel
berg sonne während ein teil der
studierenden die ersten gäste bedient
geben andrea einen kleinen vorgeschmack
auf das konzert am abend
denn das ist der clou des aromas wenn
der magische moment gekommen ist
kochschürzen und putzlappen zur seite
gelegt sind zeigt sich der wahre lohn
für die ganze zusätzliche arbeit
[Applaus]
was hände alles bewirken können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist ja gerade in der rolle der
kellner im august musizieren sie dann
ist das so für die gäste wollen sie sich
einen moment ihre gerne bis dieser
rollenwechsel für ihre gäste wenn sie am
tag sind die kellnerinnen sind sie aber
dennoch musikerin ich glaube für die
gäste ist das total spannend dass sie
die musiker und musikerinnen in
verschiedenen rollen erleben können dass
sie mit ihnen in kontakt kommen können
dass sie mit ihm sprechen können weil es
oft außerhalb des konzertsaals schwierig
ist mit musikanten musikerin ins
gespräch zu kommen jetzt nehmen sie hier
oben auch noch den puzzle abnehmen wir
haben sie stehen in der küche sie waren
eigentlich alles wie es ist eigentlich
ganz nett dadurch dass wir immer in
einer gruppe sind mit den anderen
kommilitonen zusammen wir haben sehr
viel spaß in der kirche und im
housekeeping
das ist ganz okay das ist ja aus der not
geboren dieses projekt sind gestrandet
in luzern aus studierende im frühling
aus corona aus der lok dann kam
wie hat das ihr leben verändert dieses
projekt habe man das auf jeden fall
erstmal drei monate zu hause alle
konzerte alle reisen alle projekte
abgesagt und als hotel eröffnet hatte
gab es wieder möglichkeiten konzerte zu
spiel mit den anderen kommilitonen
zusammen projekte auf die beine zu
stellen und kann man muss nicht zu
spielen
also dann würden sie jetzt auch
freiwillig gerne bleiben herz hindern
[Musik]
in den letzten tagen habe mir dieses
buch das leben versüßt elke heidenreich
in hochform männer in kamelhaar mäntel
die autorin erzählt darin aus ihrem
leben sehr berührend und sehr lustig
worum es geht ja elke heidenreich liebt
es sich zu verlieben und zwar am
liebsten in musiker da war es ja hier
ganz genau am richtigen ort allerdings
müssen die nicht unbedingt kamelhaar
mäntel tragen klamotten spielen
allerdings schon eine tragende rolle
so kennt sie das fernsehpublikum elke
heidenreich die streitlustige
messerscharfe literaturkritikerin ich
habe diese frau in diesem buch überhaupt
nicht gefunden
die hier erzählt sondern nur was sie
alles weiß was sie alles gelesen hat was
sie alles notiert es wächst sich für
mich nicht zusammen und soll mehr eine
qual zu lesen ich habe nicht einen
einzigen faden gefunden ihre
emotionalität ihre vehemenz legendär ihr
markenzeichen leidenschaft feuer und
flamme und zwar nicht nur wenn es um
bücher geht
ich verliebe mich auch stundenweise
schöne geld
es möge ihnen schmecken schon bin ich
verliebt und so gibt es auch manche
klamotten bei denen ich an schlanken
klamotten die dna von generation
ausdruck kultureller zugehörigkeit
versöhnlichkeit gewinn für heidenreich
sind kleidungsstücke vor allem ein stück
erinnerung mit schrillen mode trends hat
sie hingegen wenig am hut
in ihrem neuen buch lässt sie luftig
leichte aber auch bittersüße geschichten
aus ihrem leben revue passieren
traumhaft elegant im titel die mäntel
ihres vaters der offenbar großartig
darin aussah ein schicker frauenheld der
früh die familie verließ grau die farbe
ihrer kindheit in der schule durfte sie
nur röcke tragen mit derber cordhose
drunter im winter glück sieht anders aus
als teenager dann ein selbstbestimmtes
schwarz
wir haben mit 16 angefangen die
existenzialisten zu lesen das gab die
zeit kamen die gerade auch in frankreich
kann sagt beckett und dann haben wir das
gelesen und haben genau wie die immer
schwarz getragen das haben wir auf den
fotos in den zeitungen oder haben kette
geraucht filterlose zigaretten und haben
versucht philosophisch auszusehen und
nachzudenken
es war aber alles ausdruck inneren
unglücks und innere einsamkeit der
schwarzen rolli ist längst passé als
erwachsene entdeckt heidenreich ihre
humorvolle seite und die liebe zum
kabarett in der rolle der else stratmann
ist sie auch gast in der schweiz
[Musik]
ich habe ein bisschen elegant gemacht
ich habe mir gesagt else du gehst nach
der schweiz will daher statt kapital
muss ich reinmachen hat erzählt immer
wieder rausgeholt die groko tasche aber
ich sehe ich bin die einzige die sind
gar nicht so viel und immer wieder das
thema kleider klamotten
geschmacklosigkeit ach die habe ich
heute gerade wieder gesehen
geschmacklosigkeit jetzt kommen wieder
die herren aus den löchern mit den
kurzen hosen eine ganze hat recht immer
lange sorgen habe ich bei lagerfeld
geladen
lagerfeld und heidenreich eine filmreife
hassliebe festgehalten in einem kapitel
uns hat es die eröffnung der salzburger
festspiele 2008 angetan
nicht wissend welche gesellschaftlicher
groß event dies ist trägt heidenreich
bei ihrer rede das gepunktete kleid
ihrer mutter eine jacke kaschiert die
motten löchern nach ihrem auftritt hört
sie auf der toilette zwei damen sagen
und das fand ich so wunderbar dann bin
ich rausgegangen und habe zu diesen
beiden sehr eleganten damen gesagt aber
das war so meine rache
das ist meine lieblingsgeschichte und
das ist die einzige 100 prozent waren
ich bin ich wirklich nicht aber
geschaltet ist auch schön oder
tragischen die geschichte von nero ihren
aus italien mitgebrachten charta
verewigte sie 1995 in einem buch das ihr
millionenfach verkauft ein sorgenfreies
leben bescheren
[Musik]
in eine italienische weine kiste gelegt
und mit seiner italienischen erstausgabe
im garten begraben
und dieses kleid habe ich wirklich ich
glaube fast nie getragen das habe ich
gehofft für diesen kater so denke ich
seit 20 jahren an dieses kleid was im
garten unter dem baum liegt mit meinem
liebsten wenn heidenreich in die
klamottenkiste greift zeigt sie neue
seiten der kritikerin
ihre reise in die vergangenheit eine
schmucke liebeserklärung ans leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der zieht mit dem effizient vor dem werk
hause gebracht mit dem urban frey ist
eher was hat den ausschlag für übermut
also ursprünglich einmal wenn es heute
für musik machen wo sie doch bevor ihr
mache ich mit der familie nach einem
türken und amerikas spiele oder loctite
komisch ist für alle ist es jungen
musikerinnen und musiker musikboxen und
die nach katastrophalen ausgang ist in
klammern sich an der macht hält sie
haben da überhaupt kein thema
das heißt dass susanne sich hoffe sie
boten aber sie hat auch in lohne sich
die leute jahres vorlage und einer von
der studentin wird und daher die idee
brauchen scheint jedoch das hotel bietet
mit musikstudenten betriebe und so sehen
der übergang am anfang skeptisch sehe
und inzwischen muss ich sagen
funktioniert einfach super gut und die
schafe hochprofessionell und ja sie sind
alle zahlt noch einen
gesamtarbeitsvertrag und das ist ja auch
gange das deloitte und
verdienstmöglichkeiten und legt sie die
klinik ihrem studium noch etwas einfach
heißt musizieren zusätzliches großes
zeichnet eine schwierige zeiten wie
gesetzt dass mit der zukunft es ist
natürlich so jetzt wo normal sonntag
faktisch die neue location und mähren
dankt medici bleibe es ist bitter aber
jetzt normal ist es gar nicht braucht
und damit mir jetzt über eventuelle mit
brauche mir bei 50 franken
das wird wie lange das mittel betrieb
aufrechterhalten und tragischen ist
einfach
projektpate für alle die kogit maßnahmen
moment keine chance kam irgendwo bitte
einen kombi oder gar del potro und hoffe
ich jetzt wirklich irgend eine stiftung
oder landes crowdfunding wo ist hilft zu
überleben
ja die idee die hier oben auf der rigi
entstanden ist sie steht stellvertretend
für ganz viele kleine kulturprojekte die
momentane mehr blühen sind trotz allem
das braucht mut innovation allein das
reicht aber nichts wir schauen auf das
opernhaus zürich trotz ausgeklügelte
sicherheitskonzept muster der kultur
dampfer jetzt wieder schließen
am schauspielhaus zürich hingegen da
wird gespielt weshalb das so ist das
wollten wir wissen
zur saison premiere im september
da war die welt im opernhaus zürich noch
in ordnung trotz pandemie das opernhaus
kreierte ein raffiniertes schutzkonzept
gab eine viertelmillion franken aus um
dem publikum den vollen genuss zu bieten
chor und orchester spielten in einem
externen proberaum und wurden live in
die vorstellung des trieb die rechnung
ging auf
wir haben im kulturplatz darüber
berichtet
[Musik]
doch jetzt herrscht stille mit dem
beschluss des bundesrats nicht mehr als
50 zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
zuzulassen hat das opernhaus seinen
spielbetrieb per sofort eingestellt
mit intendant andreas homoki konnten wir
nicht sprechen
er erholt sich aktuell von seiner krone
erkrankung doch der kaufmännische
direktor christian werner stellt klar es
ist mir wichtig dass vermittler dass ich
nicht spiele ich gut spiele ich halt
der frust ist greifbar ferner rechnet
allein im november wegen der schließung
mit einem verlust von bis zu 1,5
millionen franken
vor 50 leuten zu spielen das würde das
finanzielle desaster noch vergrößern
den kann er vorstellig stelle mal sage
jetzt mal 50.000 franken verlust mache
will ich spielen will mir einfach das
publikum fällt
ortswechsel das schauspielhaus zürich
hier erhält man den spielbetrieb
aufrecht warum kann es sich dieses haus
leisten vor 50 personen zu spielen statt
vor maximal 700 also diese stadt
ermöglicht dass die tat machen können
jenseits der rein wirtschaftlichen
erwägungen klar
beide häuser sind subventioniert doch
die subventionsgelder reiche nicht um
den betrieb aufrecht zu erhalten
beide häuser sind existenziell auf die
einnahmen aus dem bild verkauf
angewiesen
das ist die crux in dieser situation
denn der aufwand vor einem fast leeren
saal zu spielen ist in etwa der gleiche
wie vor einem vollen haus für das stück
mein jahr der ruhe und entspannung sind
alle mitarbeiter an bord nur von der
bühne seite sind das wahrscheinlich so
20 bis 25 dann gibt es aber auch so dass
ein das personal also vermutlich werden
an dem abend konkret daran arbeiten dass
wir die türen öffnen können
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal über 50
grad als metapher schönen 50 cent rund
50 arbeiten daran die kosten einer
theaterinszenierung sind meist erheblich
tiefer als bei einer opernaufführung
auch die betriebskosten der häuser
insgesamt das schauspielhaus beschäftigt
300 leute das opernhaus mehr als das
doppelte
wir und hörer in die hand und ballett
und solisten die hand bühne mannschaft
mir ein berüchtigter garderobe und maske
das ist ein riesiger apparat das
schauspielhaus arbeitet mehrheitlich mit
festen ensemble fixen vertreten und
monatslöhne
das opernhaus hingegen verpflichtet oft
gastkünstler die pro vorstellung bezahlt
werden
stars wie shakira bartoli locken das
publikum ins opernhaus
entsprechend hoch sind die abend gagen
[Musik]
absolut im fünfstelligen bereich und ich
zahlte ihr name for a big und wenn ich
drei abg name hanoi nicht ausgleichen
auch das schauspielhaus muss sparen
verschiebt produktionen auf später
reduziert sein angebot aber noch wird
gespielt
eine chance trotz aller widrigkeiten die
gunst des publikums zu stärken
es gibt den großen wunsch von menschen
ansicht dass man über den alltag hinaus
gehoben wird
und ich glaube wir können gerade auch
gerade mit 50 menschen eine atmosphäre
kreieren die extrem besonders und nicht
alltäglich ist und die
aufnahmebereitschaft des publikums ist
gerade extrem groß es gibt den wunsch
sich tief berühren zu lassen wann im
opernhaus wieder die großen emotionen
den ton angeben und das publikum auf
seine kosten kommt ist ungewiss
ich glaube die große schwierigkeit von
der jetzige maßnahme ist als unbefristet
ist das ist für unser großes forderte
was ja viele zu realisieren das theater
eukitea größeren knopf wo man kann und
auch stellen pro bewerber
das heißt es großen betrieb 50 prozent
reduziert warum barmittel spielbereit
bleiben das opernhaus hat bis ende
november alle vorstellungen abgesagt
fortsetzung folgt hoffentlich bald
wieder mit publikum
[Applaus]
die aktuelle situation ist für
kulturschaffende existenziell wir von
kulturplatz möchten künstlerinnen und
künstlern die möglichkeit bieten bei uns
aufzutreten wir möchten ein forum
schaffen eine plattform bieten mehr
informationen dazu finden sie unter
www.ses.com tour platz
[Musik]
das bundesamt für kultur vergibt jedes
jahr den begehrten trick meret oppenheim
dieses jahr wird geehrt unter anderem
die kuratorin coco in kamerun
aufgewachsen als teenager in die schweiz
gekommen lebt sie heute in kapstadt wo
sie leitende kuratorin amtseides museum
ist wir haben heuer co in zürich
getroffen
cocu ist kosmopolitin geborenen kamerun
aufgewachsen im kanton aargau tätig in
senegal und in südafrika aktuell macht
sie zwischenstation im kunsthaus zürich
in der ausstellung des agierens kader
attia eines langjährigen freundes die
fragen mit denen sich gerade rat hier in
seinem werk beschäftigt sind auch die
fragen die sie als kuratorin umtreiben
wie gelingt es dem von kolonialer
ausbeutung geschundenen kontinent afrika
dieses erbe zu verarbeiten
diese geschichte der fremdbestimmung und
des leids die nachwirkungen hat bis
heute bis zu den flüchtlingsströmen des
mittelmeers
es ist traurig nicht behandelt wurde
das ist eigentlich dazu nicht sagen
und dadurch dass das trauma behandelt
worden ist kompakt jeden jeder drüber
hinweg und es ist dass wo immer wieder
rufe und wie zum beispiel jetzt mit
alten black live smarter protest und und
da ist es sich das drama vom schwarz
schwarze macht ihre arbeit als kuratorin
und kulturvermittlerin ist teil der
traumabewältigung der erste schritt
bewusstseinsbildung new york gründete
2008 die rohmaterial company ein
kulturzentrum in dakar senegal in der
angegliederten akademie und denkfabrik
haben sich bereits 150 junge
kunstschaffende weitergebildet
sicher ganz spezielle so genau die
kunstakademie mac und nicht die akademie
zum eventuelle einer kunst machen oder
lied zum lernen text schrieb oder nichts
lernen kuratieren maicon vor allem atro
zulegen die danke und zusammenhang
politische und historische zahlen
zusammen zu bringen wo dann später wenn
die flüsse auch als chefkuratorin des
museum für afrikanische gegenwartskunst
in kapstadt will sie bewusstsein und
selbstbewusstsein für das eigene
kunstschaffen schärfen
weil sie sich bemüht die afrikanische
kunst neu zu definieren wird sie nun von
der schweiz ausgezeichnet
sie sei einer der einflussreichsten
persönlichkeiten der internationalen
kunstszene schreibt die jury des meret
oppenheim preises
und sie sei eine die global denkt und
handelt sagt roger bürgler leiter des
johann jacobs museums in zürich und ein
alter freund von krockow denn globales
denken jenseits von nationalismen und
ländergrenzen wird immer dringlicher
börgel arbeitet an seiner nächsten
ausstellung über die verschlungenen
lebenslinien junger flüchtlinge die an
der odyssee hinter sich haben
genauso wie manche textilien
[Musik]
vielen dank
ach diese buijs wahnsinn
das kommt als kuba und kuba nicht die
insel kuba die region im kongo und
deshalb heißt kuba die insel kuba ein
stoff der in erinnerung ruft wie
kontinente und kulturen miteinander in
wechselwirkung stehen
coco ist selbst ein lebendes beispiel
was ein kojote für das ist auch dieses
dieser zwischen weesen charakter wenn
ich das mal so ein ende habe also ich
glaube dass man für die zeitgenössische
welt inkompetent ist wenn man nur eine
sprache spricht also es müssen schon
zwei oder drei oder vier und auch solche
sein
sie ist eine weltbürgerin die grenzen
unwichtig erscheinen lässt und das ist
doch ziemlich zukunftsweisend wie es
behältnisse schwitzig nettes verhältnis
von eure sogenannten ausladende röcke
und der schweizerin und so wenig durch
und durch kamerun in bin und so wenig
durch und durch aus senegal ist in bin
also mich über verschiedene die
identitäten in sich tragen und und ohne
konflikt dass sie eigentlich können
übertragen
selbst schaftliche definiert dass die
partie versiebte pluralität richtig dass
unsere sendung von der regel ja frische
luft und inspiration beides so wichtig
in diesen tagen kommende woche da
beschäftigen wir uns mit dem politischen
islam nach den attentaten in den letzten
wochen jetzt gehts weiter wessels mit
dem report der markt bis bald
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos